c'est le nouvel outil de la direction
patrimoine de la ville d'elancourt un
drone muni d'un appareil photo et d'une
caméra après plusieurs formations et
l'immatriculation du drone auprès de la
direction générale de l'aviation civile
la commune peut l'utiliser pour
inspecter ses bâtiments publics leur
disent ils voient call me semble que
depuis son débardeur à l'angle de la
toiture
je vais pouvoir aller vérifier ce soir
là je vais pouvoir approcher à peu près
jusqu'à honnête et là je vais pouvoir
déclencher une prise de photo donc là la
photo a été prise et là je constate en
fait qui a vraiment un souci sur l'angle
il de ces bâtiments sur cette église par
exemple on va faire un état de vétusté
indue de la toiture un état de corrosion
nous avons en haut du clocher différents
pièces métalliques qui sont à vérifier
son état de corrosion aussi décroché
dardoise on a évacué deux sticks et si
la tuile lardoise est attaquée à un état
de vétusté très avancé on peut aussi lui
mettre des caméras infrarouges qui va
nous permettre aussi d'avoir des
diagnostics thermiques de différents
bâtiments
la commune a investi près de 2000 euros
dans cette technologie une économie
d'environ 10000 euros et un gain de
temps par rapport au montage d'un
échafaudage la réactivité aussi est
importante c'est à dire si on détecte
une anomalie sur un bâtiment
on va tout de suite allé de l'inspecter
avec le drone c'est réactif c'est
instantané
en plus de l'église saint-médard les
gymnase pierre de coubertin et
chastagner vont faire l'objet d'une
prochaine étude